SOME -- RAISE SOME AWARENESS
ABOUT WHERE THIS ISSUE STANDS
RIGHT NOW.
>> ARLETTE SAENZ, GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
>>> THERE IS ALSO MORE EVIDENCE
THIS MORNING THAT ALL IS NOT
RIGHT FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN AND HIS
INNER CIRCLE.
A SENIOR RUSSIAN OFFICIAL IS
LASHING OUT AT HIS COUNTRY'S TOP
MILITARY COMMANDERS CALLING THEM
INCOMPETENT AFTER A STRING OF
LOSSES ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
FRED PLEITGEN IS LIVE IN KYIV
WITH MORE ON THIS.
WHAT ARE YOU PICKING UP?
>> Reporter: WE ARE PICKING UP
THAT THERE DO SEEM TO BE RIFFS
WITHIN THE MILITARY OPERATION
THAT RUSSIANS HAVE STARTED.
THE WAR HERE IN THE UKRAINE.
AND YOU LOOK APT THE CLOSE
ALLIES LIKE THE STRONG MAN OF
CHECHNYA, WHO FOR A VERY LONG
TIME, SINCE THINGS HAVE BEEN
GOING WRONG FOR THE RUSSIANS,
HAS BEEN SAYING THAT BIG
MISTAKES HAVE BEEN MADE AND HAS
BEEN URGING THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
LEADERSHIP TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY AND QUITE FRANKLY TO
HIT UKRAINE EVEN HARDER THAN IN
THE PAST.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER OR NOT
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY IS CAPABLE
OF DO THAT AND THE PERSON UNDER
FIRE IN RUSSIA IS THE DEFENSE
MINISTER, HE'S CATCHING A LOT OF
FLACK THAT IS SO INTERESTING SEE
BECAUSE YOU DON'T SEE THE
CRITICISM OUT IN THE OPEN AS
MUCH AS FAR AS RUSSIA AND
PRO-RUSSIAN FORCES ARE
CONCERNED.
THERE WAS AN INSTALLED FIGURE IN
THE KHERSON REGION, A LOCAL
MILITARY OFFICIAL THERE WHO
ESSENTIALLY SAID THAT THE
DEFENSE MINISTER SHOULD THINK
SHOOTING HIMSELF.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY UNHEARD OF NORMALLY
IF YOU TALK ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
SORT OF MILITARY HIERARCHY.
BUT THEY UNDERSTAND THEY ARE IN
A LOT OF TROUBLE.
AS FAR AS THE MOBILIZATION OF
EXTRA FORCES ARE CONCERNED AND
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING ON THE
BATTLEFIELD ARE CONCERNED AS
WELL WITH THE UKRAINIANS WINNING
MORE AND MORE TERRITORY.
AND IT IS QUITE INTERESTING TO
SEE THE UKRAINIANS, KATE, THEY
ARE ALSO VERY WELL AWARE OF THE
FACT THAT THE RUSSIANS ARE
HAVING THESE PROBLEMS.
THE DEFENSE MINISTER OF UKRAINE
JUST A WHILE AGO, HE CALLED ON
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS TO LAY DOWN
ARMS AND SAYING THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN LIED TO AND HAD BEEN
BETRAYED.
SO A LOT OF ISSUES RIGHT NOW FOR
THE RUSSIANS HERE IN UKRAINE.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
JOINING ME NOW FOR MORE PETER
SWACK.
HE SERVED AS A SENIOR TO THE
RUSSIAN FEDERATION AND SIMON
SCHUSTER WHO HAS WRITTEN ABOUT
UKRAINE AND PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
IT IS GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
SO SIMON, LET ME START WITH YOU.
WHAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT OFF
THE TOP WHICH IS BIDEN'S WARNING
AND ARLETTE SAENZ IS TALKING
ABOUT WHAT SHE'S HEARING FROM
SOURCES WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION NOW.
THIS WARNING OF ARMAGEDDON IF
YOU WILL.
STARK, BLUNT, YES.
EXAGGERATED THOUGH?
>> I THINK 1992 WAS MORE
DRAMATIC WITH THE CUBAN MISSILE
CRISIS.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT A
SPIRALING EXCHANGE THE MASSIVE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, CD BUSTER BOMBS
BETWEEN TWO SUPERPOWERS.
HERE PUTIN HAS BEEN WARNING
REPEATEDLY AND HIS ALLIES HAVE
BEEN WARNING ABOUT THE USE OF
TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPONS WHICH
WOULD BE BATTLEFIELD NUKES THAT
RUSSIA COULD USE TO ATTACK THE
UKRAINIAN MILITARY BASE OR THE
DECISION-MAKING CENTERS IN KYIV
THAT PUTIN IS ALSO TALKED ABOUT
POTENTIALLY STRIKING.
SO THE GOVERNMENT QUARTER,
RIGHT, PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY'S
OFFICE.
THESE ARE ALSO NIGHTMARE
SCENARIOS BUT DO YOU THINK THAT
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS WAS MORE
DANGEROUS AND MUCH CLOSER TO THE
BRINK OF TOTAL ANNIHILATION FOR
THE WORLD.
AND IT IS INTERESTING TO SEE THE
WAY THAT PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HAS
RESPONDED TO THESE THREATS.
HE'S BASICALLY SAYING TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN, OKAY, IF YOU
THINK WE'RE THAT CLOSE TO THE
BRINK, THEN DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
SO TAKE PREVENTATIVE ACTION BY
IMPOSING SANCTIONS, BY GIVING
MORE WEAPONS AND DEFENSIVE
WEAPONS TO UKRAINE SUCH AS
ANTI-MISSILE SYSTEMS SO UKRAINE
COULD DEFEND ITSELF AND THAT
WOULD DISSUADE OR DETER PUTIN
FROM STAKING THAT STEP.
AND HE'S PASSING TO BIDEN, IF
YOU SEE ARMAGEDDON A FOOT, YOU
SHOULD TAKE SOME ACTION.
>> AND WHAT WOULD THE USE OF A
TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPON THE
UKRAINIAN BATTLEFIELD LOOK LIKE?
>> UM, YES, JUST FOLLOWING YOUR
FIRST QUESTION, REMEMBER THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS A YOUNG
ADULT DURING THE CUBAN MISSILE
CRISIS.
IN 1962.
AND I THINK HE AND AMONG MANY OF
US OLD COLD WAR GUYS THOUGHT WE
WOULD NEVER, JUST COMMITTED
OURSELVES NEVER TO COME BACK TO
THIS AND HERE WE ARE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DEFINE
HYPERBOLE AND ALL OF THAT, BUT
IT WAS DEFINITELY A WAKE-UP CALL
THAT WHILE UNLIKELY, ALL OF
THESE POTENTIALS ARE OUT THERE.
AS FAR AS NUKES AND TACTICAL
USE, I BELIEVE THAT YOU USE ONE,
YOU'VE OPENED UP PANDORA'S BOX.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE WE WILL GO
FROM THERE AND THERE ARE LOW
YIELD.
THEY'RE CALLED LOW YIELD
TACTICAL WEAPONS COULD BE FIRED
FROM ARTILLERY ROCKETS DROPPED
BY AIRCRAFT AND MISSILES.
A LOW YIELD ONE WOULD BE AROUND
1 KILLA TON.
HOW ABOUT 1,000 TONS OF TNT
APPROXIMATELY.
HIROSHIMA AND NAGASAKI WERE HIT
IN 1945 WITH 10 TO 15 KILLA TON
YIELD DEVICES.
MUCH BIG.
BUT ONE DEVICE COULD DO ENORMOUS
DAMAGE TO A CITY BLOCKS, SMALL
TOWNS, CERTAINLY POSITIONS AND
SPREAD.
RUSSIANS HAVE ESTIMATED 1500 TO
2,000 OF THEM IN SMALL YIELDS.
BUT AS I SAID, YOU DROP ONE, I
THINK YOU'VE OPENED UP PANDORA'S
BOX.
I THINK THE RUSSIANS KNOW.
THE CONDEMNATION WILL COME DOWN
HARD NOT JUST FROM THE UNITED
STATES AND ALLIES BUT FROM THE
WORLD.
YET IT IS A COURSE OF ACTION
THAT I THINK IS INCREASINGLY
BEING LOOKED AT UNDER A KREMLIN
THAT IS BELEAGUERED IN ITS OWN
MIND AND UNDER SIEGE.
>> AND LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THAT, SIMON.
BECAUSE "THE WASHINGTON POST" IS
REPORTING ABOUT KIND OF WHAT
GOING ON AROUND VLADIMIR PUTIN.
SOMEONE CONFRONT THE HIM
DIRECTLY OVER HIS HANDLING OR
BOTCHED HANDLING ON THE
BATTLEFIELD OF THE WAR IF
UKRAINE.
YOU THINK THERE IS LITTLE CHANCE
THAT THIS KIND OF DIRECT
CONFRONTATION, IF YOU WILL, WILL
CONVINCE PUTIN TO CHANGE COURSE.
WHY?
>> WELL I DON'T THINK THAT IS
GOOD NEWS.
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN LISTENED TO BEFORE THE
INVASION, WE'RE TALKING A YEAR
OR TWO AGO, HE HAD A MUCH
BROADER CIRCLE OF ADVISERS THAT
HE WOULD SOMETIMES CONVENE WITH
AND TAKE THEIR ADVICE ON BOARD
BEFORE MAKING BIG DECISIONS.
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE
PUSHED OUT OF HIS IMMEDIATE
CIRCLE A LONG TIME AGO.
PUTIN GOT VERY ISOLATED.
HE ISOLATED HIMSELF FROM HIS
FORMERLY CLOSE ADVISERS.
WELL BEFORE HE MADE THE
DISASTROUS DECISION TO INVADE
UKRAINE.
AND NOW THE PEOPLE THAT ARE --
WOULD BE SPEAKING TO HIM AND
POTENTIALLY AS THE WASHINGTON
POST IS REPORTED, CONFRONTING
HIM ABOUT SOME PROBLEMS WITH THE
WAR, THOSE WOULD BE THE ONE ARE
EVEN MORE HAWKISH THAN PUTIN.
SO, IF SOMEONE IS COMING TO HIM
AND SAYING THE WAR IS GOING
BADLY, THOSE WOULD BE FIGURES
LIKE RAMSAN CAD EVE AND THOSE
WHO ENCOURAGE PUTIN TO GO EVEN
FURTHER AND USE TACTICAL NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
SO IF SOMEONE IS COMING TO HIM
WITH CRITICISM, IT DOESN'T MEAN
THEY'RE TRYING TO TELL